[Music]
this morning on the dish a new focus for
one of america's great food magazines
thanks to the new woman at the helm bon
appetit was founded in 1956
originally a collection of recipes
distributed for free
in stores now it's one of the most
respected names in food journalism
and that's what don davis is becoming
too i sat down with the magazine's new
editor-in-chief to discuss her lifelong
passion for food
and her vision for bon appetit's future
it's a veggie sandwich it's a veggie
sandwich with a lot of heart
pickled red onions it's really so pretty
it looked like art and you know i did
feel like
that was the question on everyone's mind
what's for lunch
right now bon appetit
is no longer just a magazine it's a
youtube channel
an instagram feed and for the first time
in history
a woman of color is at the helm
don have you exhaled yet not at all
there's no time to exhale i'm learning a
new industry
i'm learning new colleagues meet don
davis
a former simon schuster book publisher
obsessive foodie
and now bonap's editor-in-chief how does
it feel
it feels amazing i've always loved food
i remember
reading food magazines and looking at
the editor's letter
and looking at the title and thinking
that seems like an amazing job so i
think i'm still in shock that i have
that title
it's a welcome change for the los
angeles native and stanford grad
who left a budding career on wall street
30 years ago
to edit books she's even written one and
wouldn't you know it
if you can stand the heat was all about
restaurants
and chefs i associated food with
gatherings
i associated food with happy people and
happiness really
fast forward a few decades a pandemic
and a social justice movement davis is
tapped with revamping a magazine
after the resignation of former editor
adam rappaport last
june under accusations of discrimination
and lack of inclusiveness any company of
a certain
age and a certain size has work to do on
gender
and cultural and racial equity and so
it didn't scare me as long as the
company was committed to doing the work
food industry hasn't necessarily been
kind to
people of color or women how are you
pushing it forward
being inclusive in terms of our recipe
developers
being inclusive in terms of our
storytelling being inclusive in terms of
the opportunities that we bring
so that's one of the entrepreneurs we
feature her debut issue this month
leaned into that with a feature on
essential workers
called the hands that feed us there's a
wonderful chef
nancy brogos jackson who works at a
school cafeteria
and at a food pantry she's a trained
chef no one's
ever featured her in the pages of a
national magazine like we have and so
that's a difference of perspective that
i hope the pages
that i'm stewarding through will reflect
just diversity of perspectives
i have to listen i have to be open i
have to learn if so much
work to do in terms of learning the
history history defined the april issue
with a nod to nostalgia
and 1970 you went retro
i went retro i think i was thinking
about 50 years ago
what would have happened you know it's
looking around and i found three things
that really interested me
and just one place to get one a quarter
[Music]
and a food company called quaker oats
produced a little movie called
willy wonka and the chocolate factory
that homage to the era inspired the
dishes
for our meal what do we have on the
table beef wellington
served with some potatoes and a
delicious
green sauce that the test kitchen
director chris morocco developed
we also have the fondue it's made with
some bell pasty
cheese and some artichokes and then one
of my favorites
is the poke cake i know it's so good
really good davis has brought a bit of
herself to the magazine as well
the idea of the perfect dinner party
eating is about
community and dining with friends we've
all missed it
who are we going to eat with when we
finally can gather again and it also
seemed in a way like the elevated
s.a.t question if you could dine with
anyone
living or deceased fictional or
historical who would it be
i think you stole that little idea from
the dish
i think that i was influenced by
the greatness coming out of this studio
but it's a great it's a great it's a
great question
those questions were put to the issue's
first host
the late sicily tyson shortly before her
death
she was too busy being a pioneering
actress to actually cook so she would
have someone cook for her
but she was very specific about the menu
it would be roast duck
and fingerling carrots and potatoes
leonaes and
champagne of course and the reason i do
it this way
thinking out of the box and expanding
the palette
readers are the strategies davis is
riding on
that and a new motto just come for the
recipes and stay for the ideas and
hopefully the eye candy as well
i think it's that playboy moment you're
having
i hope you know we're as successful they
come to you
for the recipes and they get a real
story
that's right and some pretty delicious
pretty food porn as well
and dawn says you know she's been able
to those two issues she's seen and up
and ru an increase in readership
she says the more ideas the more
diversity
people their eyeballs are going to be
attracted to seeing something new
or they'll be attracted to the food porn
yeah and i'm sorry i didn't bring
anything
uh
i didn't have any treats for you today
that's all right next week maybe